[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي العيال اختيار استهلوها بابره
العنود
فرنسا
استخبارات النظام الايراني تحدد الاتحاد
الاوروبي بضرب مصالحه في اسيا اذا صنف
الحرس الثوري ارهابيا
تجنبا لتسريح العمال ابل تتبعوا سياسه
التقشف وتلغي وجبات الطعام المرجانيه
لموظفيها
هدف تاليس الاول
1-0 للنصر
بعد
المحاولات الخطيره الوصول الاخيره في اول
ظهور رسمي له كريستيانو رونالدو يشارك
اساسيا في مباراه النصر امام امام الهلال
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا قبل ان ندخل بالملف
الاوكراني لابد من الاشاره الى ان النصر
احرز الهدف الاول بمشاركه كريستيانو
رونالدو الاولى بالمباراه بين كل من النصر
والاتفاق اذا نتابع هذه المشاهد المباشره
لهذه المباراه التي تجرى في الرياض طبعا
هذه المباراه
باهتمام عالمي خصوصا لوسائل الاعلام
الغربيه وتحديدا الرياضيه بعد المشاركه
الاولى او الظهور الاول كلاعب اساسي في
منتخب النصر لكريستيانو رونالدو بعد
المباراه التي قاد فيها النصر والهلال
بمباراه وديه امام باريس سان جيرمان
الجماهير العيون اذن كما ذكرنا النصر تقدم
بهدف مقابل لا شيء امام الاتفاق
البدايه مشاهدينا من الملف الاوكراني حيث
اشترط المستشار الالمانيه
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا بتشاور مع الحلفاء
اولا بدوره قال نظيره الفرنسي انا ارسال
الدبابات الى اكياس يجب ان لا يضر بامن
فرنسا وفي كيف قال مجلس الدفاع والامن
الاوكراني ان الرئيس الروسي
بحاجه الى معركه شبيهه بالسليغراد قبل
انهاء الحرب مشددا على انه اي بوتن يعيش
في صور الماضي الصوتي
[موسيقى]
اذا ميدانيا مشاهدينا وواسطه نفي اوكرانيه
اعلن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقدم القوات
الروسيه في منطقه ذا بوريجيا والسيطره
طبعا هناك على مواقع مهمه وسط تقدم في
كافه المحاور اذا كما نشاهد هنا ونتابع
تقدم فيزا بوريجي على كافه المحاور على
المحور الشرقي الغربي وطبعا كافه المناطق
بهذه المنطقه طبعا الجيش الروسي سيطر على
خطوط ومواقع مهمه جديده قرب مناطق كما كنا
قد اعلن عنها وهي سينوجس
ومالينوفسكا بمنطقه زا بوريجيا ودممر
اسلحه ومدافع للجيش الاوكراني هناك عبر
هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر طبعا اساسيه
واستراتيجيه بالمعركه دائره بهذه المنطقه
طبعا القوات الاوكرانيه نفت هذا التقدم
الروسي بهذا المحور من زوج ننتقل الى
دونياس حيث ايضا احرزت القوات الروسيه
تقدم على كافه عدد من المناطق هنا وتحديدا
بالمحور الجنوبي الغربي وفي مناطق محدده
هي كل من راسو دلوفكا وسيفرونوي واستهدفت
مخازن اسلحه للجيش الاوكراني بمنطقه
بمحور طبعا خيرسون حيث طوقت هذه المناطق
والذي يعتبر تقدم استراتيجي
وتطويق للقوات الاوكرانيه كما كنا قد
اعلنها عنا سابقا وتابعناها بالاسابيع
الماضيه من هذه المنطقه من دونيسك تحديدا
الى خير طبعا مشاهدينا قبل ان انتقل
المناطق المحيطه بدون يسكن ايضا حول بهذه
الاسماء
بخارسون ايضا هناك تقدم روسي لهذه المنطقه
وحاول قام الجيش الروسي بتدمير همم معدات
واسلحه واعطيه لاكياس من قبل طبعا الدول
الغربيه من الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن
الامريكيين وتحديدا تم تدمير منظومه رادار
دفاع جوي امريكيه الصنع بهذه المنطقه قبل
ان اختم هناك اليوم ايضا محاوله اوكرانيه
للسيطره على الطريق السريع وهو الذي يربط
بين الثلاث المناطق الاساسيه والذي ايضا
يعني القوات الروسيه تحاول ان ترد هذه
المحاوله الاوكرانيه بما ان السيطره عليها
تعتبر استراتيجيه
استاذ تريلات
الشرطه
العربيه كيف يعني حذيفه اليوم
السياسي وهو خيبه الامل الاوكرانيه من
موضوع الدبابات
الالمانيه والاوروبيه وايضا هناك الشقه
الميداني على الارض الصوره معك حذيفه لو
سمحت
مساء الخير العيال طبعا في الجانب السياسي
ما زالت كيف تحافظ على يعني الصمت وعدم
التصريح فيما يخص تحديدا اا الدبابات اليو
بارت من قبل دوله المانيا التعليق الوحيد
الرسمي كان من الرئيس القادسي وطبعا حتى
التعليق نفسه اتى يحمل تصميم للجانب
الالماني بان هذه الدبابات سوف تسير في
اراضي اوكرانيه وان الجيش الاوكراني سوف
يستخدم هذه الدبابات لاستعاده اراضيها
المعترف بها دوليا وانه لن يكون هنالك اي
هجوم على الدوله الروسيه اي ان الرئيس قال
هذه الدبابات لن تسير على ارض روسيا هذه
محاولات على غير العاده في ردود الافعال
في مثل هذه الامور كنا نسمع دائما تعليقات
من عدد من المسؤولين والسياسيين والقاده
عن الاوكرانيين في هذه القضيه نرى الصمت
تام وعدم تعليق في هذه القضيه من قبل حتى
مستشاري الرئيس المستشار اه طبعا المستشار
الامني للرئيس فلاديمير زينيسكي ميخائيل
بودلاك الذي كانت دائما ما يعلق على مثل
هذه الامور الان نلاحظ انه هنالك صمت تام
طبعا المراقبين يرون ان اكيف تحاول ان لا
تعلق لانها تتيح الان الفرصه للغرب وتتيح
للشركاء مساله الحوار والمفاوضات مع
الجانب الالماني علها تثمر عن وصول هذه
الدبابات الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه كذلك
اليوم طبعا كان هنالك تعليق من رئيس
الوزراء البولندي الذي قال انه مرافق الذي
قال عندنا اذا ما ضلت برلين تتعمد في هذا
الامر سوف نسعى لتكوين حلف صغير ونتخذ
القرار بعيدا عن برلين ونرسل هذه الدبابات
على اي حال قال ايضا انه سيكون هنالك
تدريب للقوات الاخرانيه على الاراضي
البولنديه
طبعا وزير الدفاع الالماني ايضا قال انه
هنالك خطوه من الجيش هي تجهيز هذه
الدبابات نحن هنا نتحدث عن 19 دبابه من
اصل واثناء 10 دبابه من طراز ليو بارتن
يملكها الجيش الالماني هذه الدبابات
التسعه عشر هي طبعا هيستخدمها الجيش
الالماني في التدريب قد تنقل هذه الدبابات
الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه للجيش الاوكراني
عليه حاله ستبدا عمليه التدريب للجيش
الاوكراني على الدبابات وما زالت
المفاوضات جاريه هنالك دراسه على الارض من
قبل شركاء
لاحتياجات كيف في المرحله القادمه اليوم
كيف كلوز وهو جنرال في الجيش الامريكي كان
في منطقه خارقه في تحديدا زار وزاره
المناطق قريبه من الجبهات وعامله مع
مستشاري على دراسه الوضع ميدانيه بعد ذلك
سوف يتم بعد القرارات فيما يخص المساعدات
كذلك كثير من المفاوضات الان تجري بين
قاده الدول والشركاء اكيد طبعا اجانب
الاوكراني هو شريك اساسي في هذه المفاوضات
وعلى راسهم طبعا وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
على الصعيد الميداني
تمركزت او تركزت العمليات عسكريه اليوم في
محاور محدده طبعا محور الزفروجه ومحور
الايمان ومحور افدينتي هذه المحاوله
الثلاث هيئه الاركان المشتركه في بيانها
اقاله انه هنالك محاولات للتقدم والهجوم
ووصفتها بالفاشله وهنالك محاوله لي التقدم
في اتجاه باخد كما نفذت عدد من الضربات
بالهجمات الصواريخ وايضا الضربات
الصاروخيه في اماكن تمركز الجيش الاوكراني
كما نشر وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيا
وبالحديث مشاهدينا عن الدبابات اعلن الجيش
انه يعمل على تشكيل واحداث جديده مدربه
على اسلحه حلف الناتو لدمجها في القوات
الحاليه فيما نقلت شبكه سي ان عن مسؤولين
عسكريين اوكراديين قولهم ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تواصل التدريب بالقرب من
الحدود البلار روسيه استعدادا لربيع واضاف
المسؤولون الاخرى ليون ان قطع غيار
الدبابات الحاليه التي تعود للحق بس صوفيا
بدات في النفق عن خشيته من هجوم روسي ثالث
قد يبدا في غضون شهرين بحلول الربيع
مشيرين الى ان الهجوم قد يتم بقوات روسيه
قوامها 150,000 جندي تم تعبئهم في الخريف
الماضي وجرى تدريبهم مع وحدات جاهزه
للمعارك
[موسيقى]
خيبه امل اوكرانيه بعد ما فشلت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه باقناع برلين لارسال دبابات
الدوليه الداخليه ولكن لماذا تتمسك
اوكرانيا بدبابات الالمانيه اكثر من
ابرامز الامريكيه هذه الدبابات مشاهدينا
تعد الاقوى في العالم بعد ابرامز
الامريكيه تشغيلها وصيانتها اسال بكثير من
الدبابات الامريكيه التي تحتاج الى وقود
طائره اما الدبابات الالمانيه الصنع
فتحتاج الى الديزل لتشغيلها
وتقتصد اكثر في المصروف نتحدث عن الطاقه
من الدبابه الامريكيه وفق الخبراء
العسكريه لاوبر الالمانيه هي ايضا اخف
وزنا واسرع حركه ويمكنها ان تصيب اهداف
ادق وابعد من ابرز وهذا الامر اليه واشنطن
سابقا عندما قالت ان الصعوبات التقنيه هو
سبب الرئيسي لرفض ارسال وعشان تصلي دببات
ابراز دبابات لايوبار 2 بدا تصنيعها عام
1979 في المانيا الغربيه كدبابات قتال
رئيسيه يمكنها التصدي للدبابات السوفياتيه
طبعا ايام الحرب البارده التقديرات
العسكريه مشاهدينا تشير الى وجود نحو
1150 دبابات ليوبار لدى الدول الاوروبيه
من بينها طبعا المانيا فيما تطالب
اوكرانيا ب100 من هذه الدبابات وتقول انها
ستكون كافيه لردع الهجوم الروسيه وشانها
جمال لاستعاده الاراضي الاكرانيه دول
البلقتين
واستونيا وليتوانيا وجهه دعوه مشتركه الى
المانيا لارسال الدباباتها الرئيسيه الى
اوكرانيا لمساعده اكياس طبعا في حربها ضد
روسيا ولكنها بارين تتخوف من رد فعل روسيه
امكانيه ان تعتبر روسيا ارسال هذه
الدبابات الى كاف تصعي في الحرب مما يتسبب
طبعا باذى للمانيا مباشره لقد يعرضها
لانتقام روسيا
قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكو ان
مسؤوليات المانيا وفرزتكمون في تعزيز
التماسك الاسره الاوروبيه بالكامل عبر
المجتمع السياسي الاوروبي مشيرا الى ان
البلدان دعما اوكرانيا وشركا في او
البلدان دعم اوكرانيا ومشاركه في فرد
عقوبات ضد روسيا
نصف اثنين اوكرانيا وفرضنا عقوبات على
روسيا ومعن توجهنا الى كيبلي اعاده فتح
الطريق الذي كرسته اوروبا بعد اسابيع
قليله سنواصل دعم خيار المجلس الاوروبي
لمنح اوكرانيا
والدول الاخرى المرشحه من دول غرب البلقان
على طريق الاصلاحات الضروريه ان مسؤوليه
المانيا وفرنسا هي تعزيز تماسك الاسره
الاوروبيه بالكامل عبر المجتمع السياسي
الاوروبي
مين كاف مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مكسيميا
لاستاذ العلاقات الدوليه استاذ مكسيم يعني
هناك ناحيتين اليوم بالموقف الالماني
بموضوع الدبابات هناك ناحيه تقنيه معلن
عنها وهناك ناحيه سياسيه وهي ان التاريخ
الالماني اليوم على المحاك خوفا من
التصعيد والتهور الروسي ومن يعني ارتدادات
على الدخل الالماني وعلى الاقتصاد
الالماني هل يعني كيف تنظر الثياب الى هذه
وجهه النظر هذا
لا يخشون فقط من التصعيد اقصد الحكومه
الالمانيه
بل يعملون طيب
مع روسيا اللي عندها الاقتصاد الالماني
بنيان على الغاز الروسي ونقطه الروسيه
رخيصه في المانيا كانت اكبر مستورد
بدايه ازمه الطاقه
وارتفاع اسعار الغاز بشكل كبير في الصيف
الماضي
على الاقتصاد الالماني كثيرا بلا شك
المانيا همم
تريد ان تكون
لانقاذها وبعدين تنتهي الحرب ستبدا بشراء
الغاز الروسي باسعار رخيصه لان هو من دوني
الغاز الروسيه الاقتصاد الالماني غيره
تنافسي على الاطلاق المقارنه بالولايات
المتحده حلو حيث الكثير من الشركات
الالمانيه بدات
التدفقي والخروج من المانيا بعد بدايه
الازمه والسبب الثانيه
الاوائل ولكن على الاقل قد
يسمحون وهذا ما نعمل به في المستقبل
القريب الدول الاخرى لارسال
دبابات
الى اوكرانيا
لك اكثر من 2000 همم
دبابه من في اوروبا وفي الاحدث في اوروبا
ايضا مثلا السيد زلوشني رئيس هيئه الاركان
الاوكراني ذكر في الشهر الماضي خلال
بريطانيا
قال
بانذ 24
دبابه واذا ما وفرت كل الدول 10% من
دبابات التي لديها سوف تصل لنا 200 دبابات
وبريطانيا اتخذت القرار اللي من حين 14
دبابات
واذا ما تلقينا الدبابات من الولايات
المتحده
واضافه الى الدباباتيه همم البلغاريا
الدول الاوروبيه الاخرى
السوبيا الثاني
ستكون ادينا الدبابات ولكنها بحاجه الى
موافقه المانيا كدوله منتجه للدبابات
لتسمح للدوله اخرى لمنحنا اياها
ونحن نامل ذلك وانا متاكده من
وانتم تعلمون
مع موضوع الدبابات وهل ممكن ان تذهبوا الى
الخيار الامريكي التي رفضت ايضا يعني
بتزويده الاكياس
بوادر
يتدرب
ايجابيه ربما تكون تمهيدا
اللي ما بعد
اجراءاتيه ربما بعد بضاعه اشهر
سنحصل عليها لان الامر يستغرق وقتنا طويلا
خاصه لاعمال اللوجستيه وغيرها
باور
ربما نعمل في فتره الربيع الى الان وكما
ذكرت لا تزالوا دبابات وسوفيتيه قديمه اما
خصه دبابات الامريكيه فهي
اصعب
الوقود
لانها تستهلك وقود اصالها
امتى كنتم بيذاكروز فلا تريدو ان تكون اول
دوله ما يزودنا بالدبابات وخوفه من
التصعيد ولكننا بحاجه اليها في الاشهر
القليله القادمه
وكمان الى دوله تريدون ان تكون هي الاولى
لتزيينها بالدبابات ولكن في الربع الماضي
عندما طلبنا الاستنجرس والجابلين ولم يرغب
احد بتزويدنا اياها حتى المانيا ولكن منذ
ذلك الوقت
وبعد شهد ان النتائج على ارض المعركه
وبامكانيه جيش الاوكراني ان يحقق النصر
على راسي سياسي من المانيا اذا ما كانت
يعني
ستزود اكياس بهذه الدبابات شكرا لك استاذ
مكسيميا ل استاذ العلاقات الدوليه حدثنا
من كاف
نبقى في الحرب الاوكرانيه روسيه مشاهدينا
حيث مبادرات عده يقوم بها الاوكرانيون
لتجاوز الازمه او ازمه الطاقه في البلاد
كتدرائيه القديسه الصوفيه اقدم النصب
المعماريه في العاصمه كياف تفتحوا ابوابها
للاوكرانيين وتفرد مساحات تتوفر فيها
الكهرباء بشكل دائم والانترنت والتدفي اول
مشروبات الساخنه لتساعد طبعا الاوكرانيين
على اداء اعمالهم حذيفه عدل والتفاصيل
هذه هي كاتدرائيه القديسه الصوفيه التي
بنيت في النصف الاول من القرن الحادي عشر
في وسط العاصمه كيف
الكاتدرائيه
تمثل المعماريه والثقافيه الرئيسي للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه مع اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا
تم اغلاقها مع القليل من المتاحف
والكاتدرائيه في الاقاليم لكن مع سد
الهجوم الروسي على كيف اعيد افتتاحها شهر
مايو الماضي
لدينا في الكاتدرائيه كانت توجد كهرباء
وانترنت والناس الذين لجاوا الينا في
المعبد او في مساحه الكاتدرائيه ظل هنا
يعملون بعد هجمات الجيش الروسي على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا عانت العاصمه
كبقيه المدن الاوكرانيه من انقطاع مستمر
للتيار الكهربائي ففتحت الكاتدرائيه
ابوابها للمواطنين كمال تتوفر فيه
الكهرباء والدفء في مساحات واماكن عمل
مرحه ومشروبات ساخنه واتصالات وانترنت حيث
يمكن لاهالك القدوم لاداء اعمالهم
اعتقد ان هذا امرا ايجابيا اضافيا فبنا
الرائع ان تجلس خلف الكمبيوتر وتنظر من
خلف النافذه الى معبد القديس صوفيا
والجمالها الخلاب
الجو العام رائع فهنا يوجد هدوء وهذا مهم
ففي الوقت الراهن ايجاد مكان هادئ ومريح
صعب جدا
هنا يوجد كهرباء وانترنت بشكل دائم
ولشركاتنا هذا مهم جدا لان لدينا اجتماعات
نقوم بها عبر الانترنت مع عمنا في الدول
الاوروبيه
لعده قرون المركز الروحيه لاوكرانيا فقط
ولكن ايضا مركز الدبلوماسيه والعلوم هنا
حتى امرائكمين عقدوا اجتماعاتهم مع
السفراء الاجانب الان تعمل صوفيا كمتحف
ولكن بسبب القصف ونقص الكهرباء عادها
الاوكرانيون الى سابق عهدها والاداره تقول
انه اذا احب الناس مكان العمل هنا فيمكنهم
تركوه حتى بعد الحرب حذيفه العربيه
مشاهدينا تتابعونا في التاسعه ولكن بعد
قليل
من طالبان الاف الافغانيين في مواجهه برد
القارس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في ايران ومنذ ان صوت
البرلمان الاوروبي لصالح مشروع قرار تصنيف
الحارس الثوري الايراني في قوائم الارهاب
الاوروبيه منذ ذلك الوقت والنظام في طهران
لا يتوقف عن ارسال التهديدات عسكريه
وسياسيا ونووويا واخرها كان تهديدا
الاستخبارات الايرانيه باستهداف المصالح
الاوروبيه في اسيا اذا ما اكملت اجراءات
تصنيف الحرس الثوري تنظيما الارهابيا
طهران وعبر مسؤوليها هدد ايضا بوضع الجيوش
الاوروبيه في قوائم الارهاب الايرانيه وهو
ما اثار سخريه معارضين ايراني
البرلمان سيظهر استجابه فوريه وحازما لاي
تحرك من شانه وضع الحرس الثوري الايراني
في قائمه الارهاب او قوائم العقوبات
وسنعترف بالجيوش الاوروبيه في المنطقه
كمجموعات ومنظمات ارهابيه وسنتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه لمواجهتها
البرلمان الايراني وعضو لجنه الامن القومي
باستهداف القوات الاجنبيه الموجوده في
الخليج واجزاء اخرى من العالم في حال صنف
الاتحاد الاوروبي الحارس السوري كم منظمه
ارهابيه
لمده ساعات في لجنه الامن القومي وادي الى
بيان سيصدره البرلمان في حال ذهب قرار
البرلمان الاوروبي الى مجلس الوزراء وتمت
الموافقه عليه وسنوافق على خطنا العاجله
في البرلمان لمواجهه القرار لقد وضع قوه
عسكريه موجوده في دستورنا على قائمه
الارهاب ونحن بدورنا سنضع جميع القوات
الاوروبيه الموجوده في الخليج واجزاء اخرى
من العالم على القائمه هذا الاجراء يزيد
من الفجر
التي تقوم بها الدول الاوروبيه الثلاث
وخاصه امريكا لتاخير خطه العمل الشامل
المشتركه
وفي الاحتجاجات وقعت 30 سجين سياسيه في
ايران بينهن الباحثه الفرنسيه الايرانيه
فري بعد الخاء وابنه الرئيس الاسبق هاشمي
رفسنجاني مذكره مذكره تطالب بوقف اعدام
المتظاهرين حيث جاء في المذكره بان النظام
الايراني حكم على تلك السجينات لمده
124 عاما بعد محاكمات غير عاجله وغير
شفافه يذكر بان الامم المتحده احصت قرابه
14,000 حاله اعتقال في اربعه اشهر من
الاحتجاجات التي بدا في منتصف سبتمبر بعد
وفاه نهسه امينه بعد اعتقالها من قبل شرطه
الاخلاق
سجينات ايرانيات تجاوزن ال 60 من العمر
وجميعهن محكوم عليهن بالسجن لعشر سنوات
واكثر من نصف هؤلاء امهات وفق تقرير لمركز
المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان في ايران الذي
فضح حقيقه ما يجري داخل سجن في العاصمه
طهران التقرير كشف مشاهدينا ان بعض
السجينات الايرانيات يعان تعانين من امراض
خطيره وحياتها اولاء مهدده بالموت يوما
بعد يوما حيث يتركنا من دون علاج داخل
جدران السجن القمع داخل العنبر العام
للنساء لسجن ايفين وصافه التقرير حقوقي
بانتهاد جسيم لحقوق الانسان وان اقل ما
يقال عنه انه غير انسانيه بسبب التعذيب
والتهويل والحبس في الانفرادي لمده طويله
بعد تشكيل ملفات قضائيه لهن من قبل
السلطات الايرانيه عدد السجينات 61 واخر
السجينات الصحيفه الصحفيه مليكه هاشميه
التي اعتقلها النظام بعد ما حضرت الى
محكمه ايفين للادلاء ببعض الاضاحات منذ
اندلاع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه مشاهدينا في
كافه انحاء ايران اعتقل النظام الايراني
اكثر من 70 صحفيه لا يزال نصف الصحافيين
رهن الاعتقال اما ابرزهم الصحفيتان نيلوفر
حاميدي واله لها محمد اللتان نشرتان طريقه
قتل الشابه مهسا امين على يد شرطه الاخلاق
وتم اعتقالهن منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات في
البلاد وحتى الساعه
قصه الفتاه الايرانيه مساء مين التي اشعلت
شراره اطول موجه احتجاجه بدات بعد
اعتقالها على يد شرطه الاخلاق ووفاتها في
16 من سبتمبر الماضي
لتمتد تظاهرات لاكثر من 150 مدينه ايطاليه
حسب المعارضه على مدار 4 اشهر السلطات
الايرانيه حاولت اخفاء التورتها بمقتل
الناس امين عبر تقرير طبي يزعم وفاتها
لاسباب الصحيه
[موسيقى]
الفكره ال 40 لوفاه ماسا ميني قمع
المتظاهرون بعنف او الى ديسمبر الماضي
لاحتواء الاحتجاجات صدر قرار بحل شرطه
الاخلاق
فيما ينتظر العشرات مصيرا مماثله
المطالبه بالافراج عن مواطنهم المعتقل في
ايران الذي اوقف اضرابه عن الطعام حسب
تصريحات افراد من عائلته من اجل البقاء
على الحياه وسط ظروف صحيه سيئه وطالبت
عائله الرهينه البلجيكيه المعتقل في ايران
الحكومه البلجيكيه بان تبذل ما في وسعها
من اجل الافراج هذا وكان اوليفيا قد اعتقل
في طهران في فبراير العام الماضي وحكمت
محكمه في طهران عليه بالسجن 40 سنه واربعه
واربع 74 شلته
[موسيقى]
يعيشوا الافغانيون هذا العام شتاءا قارسا
لم يعدوه منذ اعوام طويله حيث توفى
العشرات اسرى بروده الطقس والصواضع
الاقتصادي وانساني يفقد لابسط مقومات
الحياه
كل ما تحتمي به العائلات هنا كسوه للشتاء
عرض اجسادهم تلجا العائله الى هذه الحيله
سخونه تنقذ ما خلفته الليالي البارده
الصغار
الى هنا كاسيتا هناك شتاء بارد جدا هذا
العام ولا يمكننا ان نحافظ على دفئنا بسبب
الطقس شديد البروده هذا الطفل يعاني من
الامراض ايضا انه يعاني من شتاء قاسم حقا
وليس لديه جوارب ولا احذيه ارتدائها
منازل بلا اسقف نزحت اليها مئات الاسر
الافغانيه هربا من حركه طالبا اسقتهم مر
اللجوء في بلادهم الى ان استقبلوا الشتاء
الاصعب منذ اعوام شرد وقت المئات حتى الان
سيجاره
وهطول الامطار ولا احد يساعد الاهالي
يعانون من الامراض و يموتون بسبب البرد
القارس
شاهدتم راماتت بسبب شده البرد ولم يكن
لدينا المال الكافي لشراء نعش لها
بسبب الشتاء القارس وفق اخر احصائيات
رسميه ضحايا البرد مرشحون للزياده مع
استمرار انخفاض درجات الحراره ناهيك عن
اوضاع اقتصاديه طالت اساسيات الحياه غذاء
السالم العربيه
بالعوده لمباراه التي تجمع كل من النصر
والاتفاق ضمن الدوري السعودي الممتاز
وفيها اول مشاركه رسميه للنجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو مع النصر بدا حاليا
الشوط الثاني مع طبعا تقدم النصر بهدف
مقابل لا شيء وهذه اللقطات المباشره من
المباراه
[موسيقى]
البرازيلي يخوض موسم الاول
القياده عند الكويكبي محمد الكويكبي كره
اماميه محاوله في التغطيه ابعاد بجانب
الدفاع مصراوي بدون تركيز سهله للخلف
لمسه تصل عند سعيد المولد
عطاء غريب كلا عطاء بيتي مارتينز شوط
المباراه الاول
[موسيقى]
الى الملف اللي بحيثوا دعا رئيس الحكومه
الليبيه المكلف من البرلمان فتحي باشا
غاده عدول العربيه لدعم وحده بلاده
والمصالحه بين الليبيين ودعم التسويه
الليبيه الليبيه لايجاد سلطه منتخبه تمثل
اراده الشعب كما التوجه باشاغا بالشكر
للدول التي لم تشارك في الاجتماع التشاوري
لوزراء الخارجيه العرب في طرابلس
تحفظت وزيره الخارجيه في حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه الليبيه نجلاء المنقوش في مؤتمر
صحفي عقبه الاجتماع التشاوري الوزراء
الخارجيه العرب في طرابلس على موقف الدول
العربيه التي لم تحضر الاجتماع معتبره ان
هناك جهودا سلبيه تمارس ضد ليبيا لا تخدم
طبعا الاستقرار فيها كما قال قالت
شكرا لمن حضر من وزراء ومندوبين ورؤساء
بعثات كما انني اتحفظ على موقف بعض الدول
التي تغيبت بسبب جهود سلبيه معينه بذلت
للاسف منذ ممارسه ليبيا حقها بترقص مجلس
الجامعه نقرا هذه الجهود السلبيه بانها لا
تختم الاستقرار في بلادي ليبيا استغربنا
ابتداع امانه الجامعه شرطا غير موجود في
الميثاق واللاوائح وغير مسبوقه بان تؤكد
ان هناك 14 دوله لابد ان تكتب حضورها
كتابيا مما وضع الكثير من الدول في احراج
الاصطفاف وبذلك تكون الجامعه قد اقحمت
نفسها في الانحياز الواضح لاحدى الدول وهو
ما تمنينا تجنبه من امانه الجامعه حرصا
على وحده الصف العربي والعمل العربي
المشترك
[موسيقى]
اذا المزيد من الوثائق المكتشفه بما في
ذلك تلك التي تحمل علامات سريه قبل ان
يتولى رئيس بيض منصبه هنا نعود بالتسلسل
الزمني كيف بدات واين وصلت القصه
المشاهدين بدات الثاني من نوفمبر الماضي
حيث اكتشف البيت الابيض وثائق السريه
عندما كان بيدن نائب للرئيس السابق باراك
اوباما اكتشف الوفاء في مركز للدراسات
مركز وادي للدراسات في واشنطن العاصمه
وحينها قام محمد بابلاغ وزاره العدل
بالامر وفي الثالث والرابع من ذات الشهر
اي نوفمبر الفائت قام الارشيف الوطنيه
الامريكي بسحب المواد من الخزانه واحاله
الامر الى وزاره العدل واجراء تقييم لتلك
الوثائق ثم امر بالمفتش العام باجراء
تحقيق اولي بالقضيه بعد ذلك هدات القضيه
الى تاريخ العشرين من ديسمبر الفائت عندما
اعلن عن العثور على مجموعه الثانيه من
المستندات السريه في مراب منزل بايجن
بولايات ديل وهو كانت ايضا تعود الى فتره
خدمه بيدن كنائب للرئيس في التاسع من
يناير الجاري اقر البيت الابيض اخيرا
بوجود وثائق في مركز بايجن وبعدها بيوم
واحد خرج الرئيس الامريكي عن صمته وعلق
معبرا عن تفاجئه بخبر نقل وثائق سريه في
ذلك المركز مشددا على انه لا يعرف محتواها
وانه فعل ما يجب القيام به فن السمع
مواعيد كيك
يعرف الناس انني ياخذوا المستندات السريه
والمعلومات السريه على محمل الجد وبمجرد
العثور عليها فعلوا ما كان يجب عليهم فعله
وقاموا بتسليمها الى الارشيف الوطني وقد
اطلعت على هذا الاكتشاف وتفاجئت عندما
علمت ان هناك سجلات حكوميه ما نقلها
اضافيه
وبعدها بيومين اعلن البيت الابيض ان محمد
خمس صفحات اضافيه من المواد السريه في
منزله واعلن تسلطات القضائيه تعيين محامي
خاص بصفه مستشار للقضيه وهذه المره الاولى
مشاهدينا التي خرج فيها ترامب الذي يواجه
قضيه مشابهه عن صمته وهاجم العدل الامريكي
[موسيقى]
وربما حتى البيت الابيض لم يتم رفع السريه
عن هذه الوثائق بالتاكيد
[موسيقى]
وفي التاسع عشر من هذا الشهر وتصريح جديد
بدا وكانه تعاون كبير من الرئيس الامريكي
حيث قال بيدن ان كل ما في الامر انه كان
هنالك حفنه من الوثائق تم تخزينها بالمكان
الخطا وتم الابلاغ عنها وتسليمها على
الفاضي وفي 20 من يناير الجاري ايضا اعلن
عن العثور على مزيد من الوثائق السريه بعض
هذه الوثائق بخط اليد في منزل بايدو وذلك
في بحثنا استمر
لثلاثه عشر ساعه اجرته وزاره العدل ولم
يكن بيضا وزوجته حاضرين في المنزل
[موسيقى]
حول اخر المستجدات بهذا الملف مشاهدين
الينا من واشنطن سليمان
كان كل الاعلام وكل الاراء القانونيه تقول
بان قضيه مختلفه عن قضيه ترامب لانه يعني
ليس عمدا اخفى الوثائق ولكن اليوم
نات سلسله وثائق جديده هل ممكن ان يغير
هذا الموضوع بالمنحه القانوني لهذه القضيه
حتى اللحظه لا تزال وزاره العدل تصر على
ان الاجراء
بالتفتيش في منزل الرئيس بايدا في دالاوير
كان اجراء روتيني بحت ربما لتقول اولي
تشير بانها غير متحيزه بين قضيه وثائق
بايدو وقضيه وثائق ترامب ولكن محامون في
الامن القومي قالوا بانه هذا منحى التحقيق
يمكن ان يتغير لحظه ما يتم اثبات انه تم
تلاعب من قبل همم الرئيس او حتى موظفيه
باخفاء تفاصيل الحصول على هذه الوثائق
عندها يكون التعامل مع هذه الوثائق مثل ما
تم التعامل مع الرئيس ترامب لا زالت حتى
اللحظه وزاره العدل تصر على هذا الموقف من
خلال اتصالنا له وزاره العدل مصادرنا هناك
قالت لانه من غير المالوف ان يتم التعامل
مع ملفات اساسيه من قبل رؤساء بها- بهذه
الطريقه همم حتى اللحظه التعامل مع ترامب
هو جنائي بحث لانه ترامب همم ساوا بموضوع
الوثائق تم مطالبته بتسليم الوثائق وبعد
فتره سلم قسم منها وعندما اكتشفت وزاره
العدل بانه والارشيف الوطني بانه هذه
الوثائق ليست كامله همم تم الطلب من مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي بالذهاب الى منزله
ومصادره هذه الوثائق وثائق ولكن الحال
ليست مشابهه همم
لانه بايضا واداره تتعاون بشكل تام وهي
طلبت من وزاره العدل الاهتمام بالتحقيق في
منزل الرئيس في دلاور من اجل همم ربما
العثور على وثائق ربما تعتبرها وزاره
العدل بانها مهمه
مختلف وليس صدام مع المؤسسات القانونيه
والدستوريه من سياسيه كيف سيستفيد اليوم
الحزب الجمهوري من هذه الوثائق الجديده
خصوصا انه يسيطر على مجلس النواب هناك
ايضا معركه سياسيه مفتوحه بين الطرفين
قضائيا وضع الرئيس همم جيد الى حد ما حتى
يتم اثبات عدم تعاونه هنا تاخذ القضيه
منحه مختلف سياسيا هي الازمه الفعليه التي
يواجهها الرئيس بيدر واداراته التي لا
طالما تغنت بالشفافيه وبانه ليس لها اي
همم امر لتخفيه بدءا من همم العثور على
هذه الوثائق في نوفمبر الماضي لم يتم
التصريح عن هذه عن هذا العصور حتى ديسمبر
ولا زالت الاداره حتى اللحظه تنفي
وترفض الاجابه على اسئله الصحفيين ان كان
في الاجازات الصحفيه التي يقوم بها البيت
الابيض او حتى وزاره الخارجيه الاسبوع
الاسبوعيه
يرفض المتحدثون اي تعليق على هذه المساله
وحتى اصبحت مساله حساسه لديهم همم لدى
المتحدثين ان كان متحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض كريم جون بي حتى المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه
نات برايس هذه المساله حساسه ويرفضون
الادلاء باي تصريح لانهم يعلمون جيدا لانه
وضعهم ليس جيد حتى بدات اصوات من
الديمقراطيين انفسهم تطالب بمزيد من
التحقيقات مع الرئيس ومع ادارته وهناك همم
مسؤول في الحزب الديمقراطي قال بانه من
غير المقبول ان يتم هكذا تعامل مع هذه
الوسائل وليس مقبولا من الرئيس بان يقول
هذا ليس خطائي بل خطا احد الموظفين وتحميل
احد موظفيه همم هذه المسؤوليه طبعا حديث
الديمقراطيين في اتى من بعد العثور على
الحزمه الاخيره من الوثائق والاعلان عنها
ايضا بالطبع الجمهوريون سعيدون جدا بكل
هذه تطورات وهذا المنحه وحتى هناك من قال
بانه ربما يحضرون لصفقه ما همم
يتعاملوا بها مع الرئيس همم
يضل كل الاسمات التي تحصل الان من سقف
الديون وغيرها شكرا لك يا ريت سليمان
مراسله العربيه على هذه الرساله من واشنطن
التاسعه مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
ناس تعلن والمذنب الاخضر سيطل مشددا على
الارض بعد 50,000 عام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا بالغاء الوجبات
المجانيه وتخفيض التوظيف حاليا تنوي شركه
ابل اتباع سياسه جديده لتفادي تسريح
الموظفين وفقا لصحيفه وصف جون الامريكيه
ابل هي الوحيده تقريبا التي ما زالت صامده
بين كبريات شركات التكنولوجيا التي شهدت
مؤخرا تصريحات بالجمله للموظفين ولكن ابل
ليست محصنه بوجهه تحديات الاعمال التي
اصابت عمالقه التكنولوجيا الاخرين لان
البيئه الاقتصاديه المتقلبه احيانا لن
ينجو منها احد كما اشار طبعا الصحيفه
الامريكيه والخبراء يبقى السؤال لماذا
بقيت ابل محصنه حتى الساعه السريك من هنا
مشاهدينا بان شركه وظفت بمقدار بكثير من
الشركات الاخرى اثناء انتشار فايروس
كورونا تحديدا واليوم ستلجا الى السياسه
نفسها بوابه التعليم ستقلل الابد العدد
الموظفين الجدد وستسحب الامت من هؤلاء
الموظفين عبر الغاء ما يعرف بالوجبات
المرجانيه التي تقدمها الشركه للموظفين
وهذا الامر سيتزامن مع اعلان شركه ابل
الشهر المقبل عن اول انخفاض ربع سنوي في
مبيعاتها منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات لدى ابل
مشاهدينا نحو
65000 موظف بيع بالتجزئه ويشكلون نحو 40
بالمئه من اجمالي القوى العامله في الشركه
وفقا لويس جورج واما الشركات التكنولوجيه
الاخرى التي اصابتها الموجات وموجات
تسريحه الموظفين فكانت اخرها الفا الشركه
الام لجوجل والتي صرحت موظفين على نطاق
واسع مع خطه الغاء نحو اثني عشر الف وظيفه
قرار شركه الفا بادجا بعد موجه من عمليات
التصريح الكبيره للعمال في امازون
ومايكروسوفت حيث شهد قطاع
صناعه التكنولوجيا تسريح اكثر من 200
عامل منذ بدايه عامه 2022
[موسيقى]
نبقى في الولايات المتحده حيث افاده
الشرطه الامريكيه بمقتل 10 اشخاص واصابه
10 اخرين في حادثه اطلاق نار بمدينه
كاليفورنيا ذات الاغلبيه الاسيويه واكدت
الشرطه على المجتمع به في تنفيذ الحادث
مازال طليقا مشيره الى ان العمليه تمت
اثناء احتفالات بالعام القمري الصينيه
الجديد في ما لم تكشف حتى الان الدوافع
وراء الحدث
[موسيقى]
في السعوديه وفي ظهور الرسميه الاول يلعب
النجم البرتغاليه كريستيانو رونالدو
اساسيا امام نادي النصر في المباراه التي
تجري حاليا مع ضيفه الاتفاق في مرسول باك
والتي يتقدم فيها النصر بهدف مقابل لا شيء
حتى الان وياتي هذا بعد ظهور اللافت
لرونالدو عندما قاد فريق النجوم نجوم
الهلال والنصر امام باريس سان جيرمان
فرنسيه الخميس الماضي وسجل هدفين وستكون
مهمته الاولى مع النصر استعاده الصداره من
الاتحاد الذي يتفوق عليه بفارق نقطه في
سلم الترتيب قبل ان يتواجه الطرفان في نصف
نهائي السوبر السعوديه الاربعاء المقبل
وهذه لقطات مشاهدينا مباشره من المباراه
الثاني او الشوط الثاني قبل قليل هي واحد
صف طبعا لصالح النصر
للحديث اكثر عن هذه المباراه الاجواء وكل
ما يحيط بها ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن يعني انظار
العالم اليوم تحديدا الاوروبيين وكل
المتتابعين كره القدم اتجهت الى العاصمه
الرياض مع المباراه الاولى لرونالدو كا
قائد لفريق النصر كيف هي الاجواء لديك
[موسيقى]
نعم
ليال تحدث عن ابرز عنوان الليله في ابرز
مباراه في تاريخ الدوري السعودي نتحدث عن
من حيث عدد المشاهدات من حيث
الزخم الذي يصاحب هذه المباراه من حيث عدد
القنوات الناقله التي وصلت الى 37 قناه
حول العالم في سابقه تاريخيه بتاريخ
الدوري السعودي ان تنقل المباراه بها كذا
نقل تاريخي الكثير والكل يحتشهد اليوم من
لم يحصل على تذكره وتذاكر نفذت منذ وقت
طويل جدا قبل مباراه باسبوعين ذهب واتجه
الى الكافيهات والبقائي ومن بقيه في
مشاهدته في المنازل على مستوى السعوديه
ولكنها المستوى هذه المباراه والمشاهداتها
اعلى من ذلك بكثير نتحدث عن هذه المشاهدات
المليونيه والقنوات الناقله المختلف انحاء
العالم همم حيث تعينات لك بعد القنوات
التي قادمه من هذه القنوات والناقله دول
من فرنسا ايطاليا وتركيا والبرتغال وهمم
ماليزيا وايضا غانا ونيجيريا هذا حتى
افريقيا متواجده ايضا اندونيسيا واا
بطبيعه الحال المانيا والارجواي اكثر من
ذلك ايضا على مستوى المنصات على مستوى
المساعدات التاريخيه لهذه المباراه ليال
التي حتى الان نتيجتها في تقترب المباراه
من النصف ساعه الاخيره والعشرين دقيقه
الاخيره في الظهور الاول لكريستيانو
رونالدو في هذه المباراه همم جمهور النصر
يترقب الهدف الاول وايضا عشاق كريستيانو
رونالدو يترقبون الهدف الاول حتى الان
ظهور كريستيانو رونالدو في الشوط الاول
ومنتصف الشوط الثاني كان ايجابيا مع
زملائي ساهم بهدف وايضا سهما بعدد من
الهجمات الخطيره
لتبدا رحله كريستيانو رسميه في الدوري
السعودي مع هذا ضخم العالم الذي يصاحب هذه
المباراه الان شكرا لك عبد المحسن الحربي
مراسل العربيه على هذه الرساله من الرياض
[موسيقى]
افاد مصدر في وزاره الدفاع اليونانيه ان
طائرات حربيه يونانيه رافقت طائره تابعه
لشركه راين اير كانت تقوم برحله بين
بولندا واليونان وعلامتها اكثر من 190
شخصا بعد طلاق السلطات بلاغا بوجود قنبله
وقالت وكاله الانباء اليونانيه الرسميه
وقام فريق متخصص في المتفجرات
الى تركيا حيث اكد الرئيس التركي اردوغان
ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في
تركيا ستجرى في الرابعه عشر من مايو
المقبل يذكر ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
تركيا كان من المقرر تنظيمها في الثامن
عشر من يونيو
[موسيقى]
البرازيل والارجنتين تعتزمان الاعلان عن
اطلاق الاعمال التحضيريه لتبني عمله موحده
للبلدين هذا ونقله الصحيفه عن مسؤولين ان
الخطه التي
ستناقش في قمه بولس الاسبوع المقبل ستركز
على كيف يمكن للعمله الجديده التي تقترح
البرازيل تسميتها الجنوب ان تعزز التجاره
الاقليميه وتقلل الاعتماد على الدولار
الامريكي
المذنب الاخضر سيطل مجددا على الارض بعد
50,000 عام هذه الظاهره الفلكيه اكدتها
ناسا وقدرت ان سكان الارض سيتمكنون من
رؤيتهم في بدايه فبراير ويشير الخبراء الى
انه في الاول او الثاني من فبراير سيكون
الوقت الذي سيمر خلاله المذنب باقرب ممر
له من الارض لذلك هو الوقت الانسب
باستخدام منظار او تلسكوب لمشاهده المذنب
ابهر فيديو جديد نشرته شركات باستن داينا
ميكس التقنيه الامريكيه الروبوت اطلس وهو
يقوم باعمال مبهره مستخدما يديه بطريقه
ديناميكيه منها التقاط اشياء من على الارض
ونقلها من مكان الى اخر في الوقت ذاته
يقفز بحركات بهلوايت
ايوه ايوه
الحرس الثوري ارهابيه
تشنبا لتسريح العمال ابل تتبع سياسه
التقشف وتلغي وجبات الطعام المجانيه
لموظفيها
في هذه المباراه في هذه المباراه للنصر
وفي اول ظهور رسمي له كريستيانو رونالدو
يشاركوا اساسيا في مباراه النصر امام
الاتفا
ق
ومعه هذه اللقطات مشاهدينا نختم التاسعه
لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره والان الى 360
والزميل طاهر طاهر ماذا لديك الليله طبعا
سنتابع نتائج هذه المباراه في خلال هذه
الساعه سنفتح ملف تزويد المانيا لاوكرانيا
بالدبابات بشكل مفصل وكذلك ملف اقاله اريا
درعي في اسرائيل